face à la suite de l'émission en face à
l'hyper view suivantes mais en fait
c'est une double hyper vives et je sais
c'est d'être à nouveau allez on est sur
deux personnes en même temps avec deux
personnes en même temps c'est une double
interview et nos invités ce soir son
arlette laguiller et françoise de
panafieu
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
j'ai des limons soir alors j'avais
qu'elle venus ensemble parce qu'elle se
sent mais toutes les deux sur leur 31
soit de panafieu bonsoir on soit donc ce
qu'on va faire je veux d'abord vous
interviewez séparément un quelques
questions comme ça un peu à chacune sur
votre ce que vous faites ce que vous
avez fait et ensuite on va passer à des
questions croisées sa proposera les
mêmes questions à toutes les deux et
on verra comment vos réponses s'opposent
ou certaines fois se retrouve 5ème dire
aux téléspectateurs qui se serait
absenté trois minutes qu'on a changé de
sujet bon alors arlette laguiller donc
nous nous on se connaît depuis 1996
étiez venu dans un bain de minuit et
signe des premières télés disons vous
aviez fait à parler les celles qui sont
offertes aux candidats des
présidentielles qui voit là et vous
n'avez fait l'heure de vérité quand 95
donc c'est quand même huit ans après
bain de minuit c'était la première fois
que j'étais maquiller à l'heure de
vérité là aujourd'hui vous êtes
maquiller oui oui vous maquiller
maintenant pour la télé depuis 95 ou m'a
convaincu que c'était mieux il sait bien
et c'est mieux quand vous êtes alors
pourquoi pourquoi vous êtes là c'est que
vous êtes effectivement tout le monde en
parle parce que vous êtes crédité de 8 %
aux européennes par les derniers
sondages donc c'est beaucoup mais
surtout il ya 45 % des français ça c'est
dans l'événement du jeudi cette semaine
45% des français qui approuvent arlette
laguiller
ça veut dire qu'ils vont voter pour
arlette laguiller mais globalement il
l'approuvent
je voudrais quand même atténuer un peu
mou en partie jeu pourrait atténuer vos
propos s'il est un peu flatteur
vis-à-vis dans les taillis et certaines
obtient bien douzaine d'écoles mais
quand même je voudrais rappeler qu elle
a été candidate en 74 à l'elysée à 80 88
ans 95
elle a enfin obtenu 5 % 95 des
mathématiciens calculé qu'à ce rythme-là
il pouvait être élu en 2000 97
et les sciences exactes mais si ce n'est
même pas compte steam ans et des
réactions
tout à fait lorsqu'il faut dire aussi
moi je vais continuer à être flatteur ce
qu'il faut dire aussi c'est que vous
êtes même numéro 14 dans la liste des
gens qui font le plus pour la france
j'avais pas vu généraux quatorze sur 60
millions de gens je trouve c'est pas mal
alors vous êtes porte-parole justement
ce n'est pas par hasard vous a été
choisie vous êtes porte parole de lutte
ouvrière en fait ouvrir ces deux noms du
journal en fait le parti s'appelle
l'union communiste
on dit beaucoup de choses savez on dit
beaucoup de ceux-ci est connue sous le
nom de lutte oui beaucoup de choses
depuis 1968 way
je traduis pour rocco siffredi curieux
ouvrière du parti radical fonctionnement
un fonctionnement cette émission il est
obligé de tomber dans l'extrême moi
aussi parfois extrêmes
votre parti un fonctionnement secret
quand même alors là de votre parti un
fonctionnement secret c'est que vous
avez pas parlé de ça voilà voilà
bravo dit non pas du tout si j'allais
vous avez répété serra goût de changer
de sujet pas une autre je suis désolé
mais qu'est ce que j'ai lu ce justement
dans un journal que notre journal lutte
ouvrière a été déficitaire mais pas du
tout comme ça que tous les comptes de
lutte ouvrière sont publiés au journal
officiel et atteindront le battre votre
parti qui s'appelle hardy personne n'y a
pas de patron à lui tout il ya des
camarades qui s'estiment qui discutent
entre eux qu'ils élisent une direction
qui désigne porte parole plus tôt une
porte-parole
ce qui est rare d'ailleurs parce que je
vais bientôt être la seule femme je
crois dans cette liste aux européennes a
dirigé une liste et c'est tous les soirs
dit par exemple on le connaît pas nous
mais parce que vous vous connaissez pas
la moitié de notre direction c'est bien
parti secret parce que je ne sais pas ce
crack un parti a quand même le droit de
savoir et de choisir par qui il se fait
représenter
et nous nous construisons un parti
principalement dans la classe ouvrière
de ce pays et nous voulons que nos
représentants
que ceux qui se font élire soit des
travailleurs durant parce que oui nous
pensions à dire que monsieur la classe
ouvrière est capable de chars
société ce qui voudrait dire que le
monsieur a redit n'est pas un travail on
dit que c'est le patron d'un laboratoire
à ce type moi qu'est ce que c'est que ça
excusez moi j'allais dire conneries je
les conneries que tu arrivé chez vous et
arlette s'est déclaré vous savez très
bien tous les sens et vous savez très
bien desservi
et
bien sait très bien que c'est dans toute
la presse ce qui est triste pour la
profession de journaliste c'est que ça a
été écrit une fois et c'est
périodiquement rock aux accents alors
j'espère qu'on les aura des monarchistes
j'espère que les procès qui doit avoir
lieu bientôt contre tous ces
journalistes accords vont nous rendre
justice d'accord bon voilà ce qu'on peut
dire pour finir de vous présenter c'est
votre partie basse est le seul parti
c'est trotskiste donc ça jamais été
essayé il faut bien le dire c'est votre
chance c'est sûr que quand on vous parle
l'urss de la chine de cuba du cambodge
vous dites que c'est pas des pays
communistes vraiment cédé pays stalinien
mais que c'est pas comme lui seul sait
que les autres et que moi je dis pas
aujourd'hui frem dire aussi qu'elle a
travaillée arlette la guitare j'ai envie
de vous appeler arlaten excusez moi elle
a travaillé dans une banque pendant
combien de temps mais depuis 56 à bas
pendant 40 ans oui depuis je suis en pré
retraite des retraités l'école normale
supérieure des institutrices et elle est
rentrée comme mécanographe r j'ai étudié
son cas parce qu'il est elle a été là au
crédit lyonnais il faut des sites au
crédit lyonnais
au secteur crédit immobilier c'est vrai
oui c'est vrai alors donc vous aviez
l'équipe qui venait vous voir et qui
vous disaient bonjour madame je voudrais
un prêt pour acheter un appartement avec
terrasse dans le xvième qu'est ce que
vous leur répondit les travailleurs
travailleuses mais j'avais passé pouvoir
de dire oui ou de dire non j'avais
simplement à rentrer les informations à
monter les dossiers les décisions se
prenaient au dessus ils ont dit on dit
que l' incendie du crédit lyonnais
c'est vous parce que ça faisait ça
faisait 30 ans vous réclamez un cendrier
depuis 74 la grève m'a brisé la voie
parce que pendant deux mois j'ai dû
parler beaucoup et après j'ai cessé de
fumer complètement en tout cas ça nous a
bien servi la banque parce que si elle
est aussi naturel devant les caméras
c'est parce que là-bas et s'entraînait
évidemment il ya une caméra qui l'a
surveillé toute la journée dans les
services ou les câbles dans une banque
pour savoir si elle ne prenait pas du
pognon au passage les clients sont
surveillés aussi avec les emprises n'y a
qu'à voir que tu dois surveiller la ba
oui c'est dommage ça aurait été bien
qu'elle ait la levée du secret bancaire
pourquoi je trouve fort bien en tout cas
qu'elle n'ait pas changé depuis 74 pour
moi c'est toujours la même salle est
restée aussi les mains sales et maigre
elle n'a pas grossi
quand elle parle des gens qui ont faim
on y croit à côté de martine aubry
c'est vrai c'est bien je trouve et bien
pas bien fait comme dit que je suis
mince et fluette pas gros progrès avant
avec toujours le même pull overs je vais
la regarder maintenant ça devient plus
chic au sein du temps mais campagne
électorale je l'avais déjà il ya trois
ans revient avec vous c'est que vous
êtes toujours faut que ça change faut
que cela change en fait vous changez
jamais cessé ça vous êtes peut-être
comme france 3 mais ça marche très bien
la france
vous êtes fidèles défier votre premier
retrouver l'année prochaine
sérieusement les roms comme ça avec vous
êtes dit merci pour en finir avec cette
présentation donc votre père et c'est
justement comment se passe c'est pas
fait exprès mais enfin savez à quel
point vous opposer à françoise de
panafieu votre père elle s'appelait
louis il était ouvrier enfin il a en
commun avec le père de françoise de
panafieu loyer il a été ouvrier après
votre père a été prisonnier de guerre et
le père de françoise de panafieu était
très proche du général de gaulle donc là
dessus vous pouvez pas vous ne pouvez
pas déjà il y aura pas de discussion sur
toi hitler staline ce qui en france est
quand même déjà ça de gagné en france
c'est la base de toute discussion
politique en général votre mère
s'appelait susan elle était secrétaire
est vécue aux lilas dans un tout petit
appartement et il ya des moments on a
sans vraiment tomber dans le
misérabilisme mais c'est vrai que dd
jour où manger pour dîner du café au
lait avec du pain il n'y a pas
d'électricité donc c'est quand vous
parle de la classe ouvrière ce que je
veux dire c'est que vous l'avez vraiment
connu quoi c'est pas c'est parce qu'on
se rappelle plus que moi je suis né en
40 cas la fin des années 40 début des
années 50 on connaissait cette misère on
connaissait les sans domicile fixe
prévenu les parents et les frères da une
pièce cuisine
il nous est arrivé des bergers trois
personnes qui autrement dormaient dans
la rue
donc oui j'ai connu j'ai connu tout ça
et j'ai je crois que j'ai eu conscience
assez vite des différences de classes
des inégalités d'elle ça je suis senti
la présence de madame de panafieu que
vous avoir un appart à la mairie
desjardins est on l'a fait pour lui a
donné quelques chaises j'ai pas ma carte
du rpr
pour finir pour finir ses disques ou
françoise de panafieu pour bien vous
n'êtes pas mariée à vous êtes ceni curé
ni mère ni dieu ni maître vous ceni cure
énumère nous approcher il n'ya pas
longtemps justement vous êtes ici chez
nous c'est vrai que c'est curieux pour
vous deux femmes politiques comme ça
qu'il passe derrière un sujet avec rocco
siffredi et on vous a justement
reprochés et a pas longtemps dans les
hebdos telle est votre participation à
une émission de tf1 y a pas photo qui
était consacrée aux riches et moi j'ai
lu des tas de papiers mais qu'est ce
qu'elle fout la rage et la grille et
alors est ce que vous craignez pas qu'on
dise la même chose ce soir pour cette
émission je m'en moque complètement
moi je dis ce que j'ai à dire où je
tourne une embellie en 87 je pense que
le plus gros est fait depuis longtemps
c'était fichu de toute façon après donc
j'avais un petit film porno
ok vraiment pas tout à l'heure avec
rocco il n'y a pas de beaucoup de
s'éloigner un peu parce qu'ils
commencent à me chatouiller en parlera
de romance tout à l'heure bon alors
avoue françoise de panafieu donc nous on
se connaît pas et on sait jamais vu moi
je t'ai vu à la télévision bien
évidemment donc fait une entrée en force
sur le marché des futures mères de paris
ça faut reconnaître un sondage dans le
jdd où s'étire en tête de la droite mais
réduire mae donc pour les municipales de
2001 bien évidemment donc c'était devant
tiberi madelin et balladur et à gauche
c'était dsk
je me souviens plus du chiffre était à
combien dans le sondage s'étaient 60%
dans des fonds des parisiens n'ont pas
je ne peux même plus vous dire le
chiffre exact à vrai dire je sais quand
tous les cas c'était un sondage que j'ai
pas traité avec désinvolture mais qui
concernait quand même 600 personnes
c'est à dire c'est tout de même pas la
terre entière d'accord on va vous étiez
première d'autant plus qu'en 2001 c'est
la mairie de paris l'action pour la
mairie de paris x et un an avant la
présidentielle et que c'est quand même
ça va être assez important vous
présentez pas vous et puis de matisse
dans la capitale municipal aux lilas
j'ai pas sûr que ce soit le sujet de
portée
nationaux j'ai mentionné je dirais pas
que tout le monde en parle
certains pas aujourd'hui ça va pas nous
occuper ça va nous occuper plus
longtemps parce que de toute façon c'est
en 2001 et d'ici là
alors qu aujourd'hui présentement vous
êtes adjoint au maire pour les parcs et
les jardins alors si c'est vous qui avez
autorisé qu on aille flirter sur les
pelouse
eh oui
[Applaudissements]
fourmies en dise pas autant mais c'est
vrai qu'on prend encore là il commence à
faire beau et chaque fois qu on
s'allonge sur une pelouse gelée rocco
bon c'est vous aussi parce qu'avant les
jardins les parcs et jardins vous étiez
la culture c'est vous qui avez fait 18
francs 18 heures au ciné voilà donc ça
c'est bien aussi
tout ça même fait démarrer des films qui
étaient avait un démarrage un peu
difficile alors mis un petit coup d'oeil
ils appellent ça le clic de booster
faire des efforts plus il est bas en
plus ça on sait que c'est gratuit
j'y suis allé j'ai vu un film chanté
18h18 francs 18 spectateurs s'étaient
trafic d'influencé alors donc vous êtes
vous êtes ex-ministre du tourisme pense
fâché avec tout le monde ici un
gouvernement au gouvernement juppé
ouais donc c'est une jupette faut bien
le dire a besoin pas dire qu'on a sorti
au printemps la rentrée lumière voilà
vous a été viré recasé à l'unesco quand
même on attend un nom sympa ce qui m'a
permis d'ailleurs fortement marche
voilà un grand temps alors de son
international autre papa on parlait tout
à l'heure du père d'arlette laguiller
donc vous c'est françois missoffe qui
est résistant de la première heure donc
encore une fois il on sent comme un
projet de gaulle carte de l'umr numéro
01 donc là on peut pas faire mieux avec
deux breaks avait 0-0 votre perte de 0,1
et ministre de la jeunesse et des sports
en 68 votre père mon père il a été
surtout il a suivi pendant les dix ans
du gène quand général était président de
la république
mon père a eu cette chance d'être l'un
de ses ministres pendant dix ans donc
pendant 10 ans que sa vie il a côtoyé un
homme hors normes
alors votre maire là ça va beaucoup
choqué arlette laguiller je suis désolé
là parce que là c'est tout ce que vous
n'aimez pas épuisé les traits bien léger
finale et c'est complet ce don encore
hélène 2000 tri dynastie wendel alors
vous qui en avez toujours après les
maîtres des forges la cible et de lait
devant vous la représentante à la
descendante des vandales voilà une
branche wendel mettre des photos et la
violence qui peut expliquer que madame
de panafieu soit à droite témoin à
l'extrême est ce que justement on a les
idées de sa classe sociale
impossible d'avancer moi forcément y est
c'est vrai dit fils de bourgeois qui ont
eu fin de la fin des autres ils sont
engagés aux côtés de classe ouvrière
mais c'est pas je puisse pas exactement
le cas du rt est très réussi leur père
n'est pas intervenu mi juillet le
chiffrier deux fins comme ça en face
l'une de l'autre
je crois qu'elle s'entendre est
remarquablement malgré certaines
différences parce que je crois que ce
qui base la relation des gens c'est la
sincérité
or si arlette laguiller est une femme
que je crois profondément sincère dans
sa démarche
j'ai une mère qui est également d'une
intégrité d'une sincérité totale dans la
sienne vous mettez deux personnes de
qualité en face l'une de l'autre
quelles que soient leurs différences
elles se trouvent donc la prochaine fois
nous inviterons
le cadre est très fort dans votre
vis-à-vis d'arlette mais oui mais
évidemment mais pas d'arlette vis-à-vis
d'eux c'est pas bien
si elle sait pas faire les épinards et
donc alors votre on veut terminer votre
enfance bah oui vous savez ce n'est pas
de votre faute vous avez comme votre
père était midi général de gaulle de les
côtoyer chaban-delmas messmer debré
poniatowski bon mais je savais qu'il ya
pire
oui vous êtes très lié avec les enfants
de se dire toulouse est ami avec jean
louis debré on nous sommes restés très
curieusement les enfants des ministres
du général
nous sommes restés liés de manière
presque irrationnel c'était une vraie
famille
alors moi je serais quand même profité
de la présence animale de panafieu parce
qu'elle est à la mairie de paris
times dans laquelle nous parle du maire
de paris monsieur rocco tiberi on
l'appelle comme ça tu tombes dans des
films x comme xavière j'ai entendu dire
quand même qu'il y avait un projet si la
place de la concorde et et piétonne de
faire parce qu'il ya trop de piétons
place de la concorde
une circulation alternée des piétons
avoir un passe-droit ou jeu
chez les ménages est sorti ce qui
chausse du 35 37 39 41 et 43 vous allez
brommat rendu à ceux qui ont une voiture
donc si on dirait numéro 40 40
ça va me litres marcheront les jours
pairs il paraît qu roland dumas qui est
un pied plus longue robe circuleraient
librement tous les jours
j'ai fait doublement technique figari
droite sert tous les jours tous les
jours merci samara très bien ciblé sur
bon pour terminer et encore une fois
c'est pas pour vous opposer mais c'est
comme ça vous n'êtes pas mariée en toque
quand même vous avez c'est bizarre comme
c'est vrai comme déjà problème ans
d'origine évident et alors vous vous
n'êtes pas mariée tout ça vous n'êtes
pas d'enfant vous et huit enfants
vous avez quand même temps vous étiez
sûr de vous avez mené de 88 8 enfants et
nous en met 4
reste que quatre c'est ça et votre mari
qui de panafieu dans quel président de
bulles oui c'est exactement
ouais voilà donc vous voilà à présenter
maintenant j'ai tout dis là on a tout
dit normal mais là on va maintenant on
va vous faire réagir sur des sur des
sujets précis brièvement je vous le
demande à toutes les deux un brièvement
dans un peu du coq à l'âne comme ça va
passer d'un sujet grave des fois un
sujet pas grave on va commencer avec
vous arlette laguiller
vous écrivez quoi quand on vous demande
un autographe ou non mais t'es quoi ça
dépend ça dépense c'est quelqu'un de
proche quelqu'un qui dit bank ag
l'émission en vous demandant une auto
pas vous écrivez quoi vive la révolution
s'est mis à rouler tout oui c'est
possible aussi si j'ai le temps de
parler un peu avec lui pour voir s'il
acheter le livre par curiosité ces
paroles de prolétaires camarades voilà
je le montre à la caméra
voilà donc ça s'est déclenché tout
madame ça c'est la vie darna t pas
malgré 10 et le titre avoue françoise de
panafieu même question on vous demande
des autographes vous écrivez quoi elle
signe ardèche à qui je demande le prénom
de la personne en danger mais son prénom
c'est tout et je mets mon nom à moi
c'est tout vous y trouvez pas une petite
pas fortiche si je ne connais pas la
personne c'est complètement alors autre
question pour vous maintenant la parité
dieu est amour dieu est amour voilà vous
mettez ça vous
l'huile comme bien en dessous des 2 le
matin deux le soir comme ça c'est fort
comme truc que les gens ils pensent bien
le matin et le soir
la parité homme-femme est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est bien parce que c'est
bien de protéger les femmes comme comme
une espèce qui met devraient être
protégés côté je partirai courant
d'idées cas pas besoin de quotas pour
d'abord mon courant est représenté par
une femme plus dans les élections qui
viennent il y a sur les dix premiers de
la liste oui femmes ce qui veut dire que
si nous avons des élus à part notre
camarade alain krivine qui est en
deuxième position derrière moi là bas je
crois sur la ligue 45 femmes et 42
sommes donc ça cela dit bon je comprends
que dans certains partis les femmes se
battent pour cette réalité je tiens à
parité pourquoi protéger ses députés à
l'assemblée nationale donc tout à fait
différent donc là nous on a eu vraiment
à se prononcer pour sur ce projet de loi
est au début quand on m'a parlé de la
parité j'ai trouvé la première fois il
ya deux ans que j'ai entendu ce mot
comme possible de l'inscrire dans notre
constitution j'ai été très choqué et
puis au bout du compte je me suis dit
d'abord que nous n'étions pas une espèce
comme vous le dites mais que nous sommes
la moitié du genre de l'humanité et que
deuxièmement et que deuxièmement mais
vous n'êtes pas mal non plus et
deuxièmement
celle ci serait dit je sais les efforts
mais il faut vous en remettre aussi le
droit de donner notre avis bien sûr et
qu'en 1947 nous étions 5 7% à
l'assemblée nationale est qu'aujourd'hui
nous avions été au lendemain des
élections législatives derniers jours
donc vous pensez que je me suis dit
qu'est-ce qui est le plus humiliant pour
une femme
est ce que c'est d'avoir à en passer par
la parité ou est ce que c'est de rester
indéfiniment à 5,7 pour cent de la
représentation nationale est passé sans
état d'âme que j'ai choisi de voter pour
la parité mais voilà vous allez répondre
une pièce prestation digne de jean
girault 2 c'est aussi la femme préférée
mon personnage préféré elle dit le
cheval yorn ça lui dit mais est-ce que
c'est trop te demander de te dire que tu
m'aimes alors il dit ouais je t'aime et
elle dit mais décrit moi ma victoire tu
renonces acquis pour moi il n'y a rien
ou presque rien toutes les femmes dit
les impurs laisser les excitante les
moustaches es2 à es10 toutes les femmes
et elle se reprend au dîner elle dit
owens
je voudrais offrir l'univers et voici
que j'ai autant retire la plus belle
moitié
je suis comme ça avec tes 26 cm tu peux
y aller
c'est une brique c'est avec ma langue en
se regardant soit de panafieu vient
d'inviter jean marie bigard a dit m
messieurs je vous tiendrai au courant du
développement
je ferai un commentaire en direct de
l'évolution de la situation ici bon jean
marie bigard mais vous connaissez le
prix d'un ticket de métro vous
non j'ai bien peur que non moi je suis
je suis scooter depuis deux ans que je
travaille plus je sais plus
j'avais la carte orange avec giscard qui
savez moi je prends le rer vers terre
neuve et que giscard d'estaing qui
connaissait pas le prix du ticket de
métro maintenant je m'aperçois que c'est
franc 85e françois tu sais c'est un peu
plus cher que les nuggets ainsi voilà
ses 55 ans arlette laguiller on va faire
une carte question comme ça un
commerçant se trompe en vous rendant la
monnaie vous lui dites il vous donnera
un centre plus vous vous le voyez ce que
vous lui dites annonce aussi donnent
plus ou moins bien sûr je donne mon
jeune pêcheresse demande quelle va être
la réponse oui je me barre avec les
enfants je sais pas juste a dit non mais
j'y tiens aux petits commerçants de mon
quartier parce que quand vous lui dites
la vie est difficile dans les quartiers
populaires et saccagé un quartier une
animation bon j'ai franchement tu sais
chérie je ne sais pas aller chez fauchon
alors là je les garde
c'est ça les missions
bonsoir et bonne année chez tati j'ai
cinq enfants de - soyons clairs je vais
sur ma circonscription bon match mais
pas car c'est facile de moi moi j'ai un
gros défaut
enfin c'est aussi peut-être une qualité
gens s'aiment pas je fais confiance et
je me rends compte en écoutant votre
question que c'est rare sauf si je donne
un gros billet mais ça m'arrive
rarissime en de vérifier je retombe pas
en fait je fais je fais confiance à
celui qui me rend la monnaie
ouais c'est curieux je ne sais pas ce
réflexe de recompter mes pièces ah ouais
quand c'est des fois sans le vouloir on
peut voler des commerçants j'ai par
contre la prochaine fois j'irai au
prépuce
alors là tu es ce que vous êtes pour la
taxe tobin taxe personne souffle moi je
suis pour prendre sur les profits des
grandes entreprises pour toi et des
enfants alors qu'ils veulent justement
je vois c'est françois cuzon le plus
veut le moins d'automobiles je ne suis
pas forcément contre la taxe tobin
chevaux je suis en gros pour taxer les
placements spéculaient trévoux france
les plugins y demande à tout petits pas
mais ce qui demande tout petit comtoise
de panafieu non j'ai pas d'idée de
circulation digérer cette ville que idée
absolument géniale
ces légendes du monde diplomatique et on
parle très bien il ay demande contactez
toutes les transactions d'argent de 1%
et si on arrivait tout tout l'argent qui
circule toute la journée dans le monde
sait ce qui se fait tout le temps
déclare gens bougent en emprunts oui
mais c'est pas atteint on prend des
cibles ça permettrait d'éradiquer la
pauvreté
ne croyez pas sur la spéculation sur la
spéculation s'agit d'une bourse à
l'autre pour spéculer qui fait que des
économies s'écroulent comme en ce moment
au brésil ou en asie
bon alors je crois que ça règlerait pas
le problème de la spéculation mais ses
concurrents c'est comme demander une
taxe supplémentaire sur l'argent sur le
profit sur ce qu'ils gagnent jamais
concurrencer un autre façon de faire la
révolution la taxe tobin non au ça
suffirait pas ça suffit pas mais a
évidemment nous le savez très bien
d'ailleurs
bah quand même à ça je sais pas les
chiffres parce que je savais très bien
je le sais très bien alors eh ben dis le
moi je le sais je le sais très bien
ces demandes par des révolutionnaires la
taxe tobin ses conseillers
kennedy prix nobel pour ses travaux sur
les spéculateurs états unis c'est
quelqu'un qui cherche un petit peu à
limer les ongles du capitalisme parce
que il ya même des capitalistes qui se
rendent compte que la société la patrie
c'est vrai vous êtes combien d'argent
sur vous arrête je sais pas où dans la
loge si vous l'avez décès dans la loge
si vous la laissiez je ne savais plus
rien à 300 francs nous les donner
maintenant les postiers du pognon il ya
un truc même qui est très clair le
pognon le chômage mais je suis content
de parler avec deux représentantes comme
ça charmant de la politique ou du
gouvernement tout ça parce que le pognon
faut quand même expliqué un jour aux
gens que les gens riches sont de moins
en moins sans plus en plus riches et de
moins en moins nombreux c'est une
pyramide et bien que les pauvres ils
sont de plus en plus beau et de plus en
plus nombreux et que ça c'est un truc
logique si je suis choqué non ce qu'on
fait avec 200 francs et gens qui le font
avec 200 vidéos tout simplement
et puis du chômage fait arrêter faut
dire aux gens elle y aura pas de moins
en moins de chômage y aura de plus en
plus de chômage chaque fois qu'il y aura
une machine qui sera pas syndiqués qui
pot qui gueulent rappaz qui travaillera
jour et nuit
en fermant sa gueule en travaillant
mieux que 10 personnes qui frappa chien
compte dans le bain il y aura toujours
il y aura de plus en plus des chemins je
sais ça c'est pour ça que si on devait
mais voilà vous avez indiquée on marque
en vivre
que mes mots moi mon truc c'est vrai
mais en fait c'est bien d'être des voix
mais si dans son quartier on se prenait
si nous la hauteur de ses tables on se
prenait chacun quatre ou cinq clodo qui
sont dans la rue on règlerait le
problème d'ailleurs les entreprises qui
ne sont pas gouvernementale et qui donne
l'exemple comme par exemple les restos
du coeur sont des gens qui donnent
gratuitement de leur temps pour les
autres et c'est ce qu'on attend de tous
les élus c'est qu'il ne soit pas au
service de leurs propres intérêts mais
au service justement des autres et ça on
ne peut pas l'institutionnaliser c'est
pour ça que les restos c'est des gens
qui pique une gagne pas de fric et qui
viennent aider les autres parce que si
c'était institutionnalisée suffit pas
non mais si j'avais envie d'un sauf que
les le nombre de repas aux restos du
coeur ils augmentent chaque année c'est
pas une solution
les pauvres les chômeurs que cette
solution les salariés avant jeunesse
tout seul je me sens noble art de la
chaussée côté chacun jeunes un emploi
soit les russes vie normale ce que je
lis je ne sais pas si je mange moi ce
que je propose c'est que si on veut
changer le monde il faut changer d'abord
soit c'est john lennon c'est ça qui
baisse avait été dit à 3000 comme ça
qu'on fait sur l'échangé de mots
changent et je tenais chaque fois qu'on
incitera les gens à s'occuper de leur
prochain c'est pour ça que moi je suis
plus dans l'équipe dans les jambes je
que de soutenir jean marie jo
bien sûr il y en a je suis convaincu
vous en avez qui je vais mouiller la
chemise bleue
bien sûr j'en suis convaincue mais
seulement l'ennui c'est 200 chiffres
maîtrise brume et ouais mais l'ennui
c'est qu'il y en a trop que taper dans
la caisse et maintenant on peut plus de
reconnaître ceux qui sont vraiment
gentils de ceux qui sont pas tout à fait
gentil et ça c'est un gros problème
vient parler de mon film là c'est trop
tôt rocco qui s'impatientent sais pas je
vais pas tenir
vous m'en donnez une se passer quelque
chose à toutes les deux avant de parler
avant de passer le talk-show
passionnément macho mais joe dimaggio
non c'est chaud d'ailleurs gentiment ses
coûts de bigard je vais lui donner une
cuillère sur skins us qui fait pas je
suis d'accord pour le faire vdax fr
mesdames et messieurs ce assez macho
ouais non ça c'est pas macho parce que
ça c'est mon grand père qui me faisait
ça regardez bien et pas d'une cuillère
comme ça c'est le moment le palace vous
regardez c'est à regarder dans les
cuillères briller dans la cuillère c'est
le plus beau si ce n'est qu'ils savent
les frais d'une cuve est vidée à ses
rêves les pieds vous le voyez vous
regardez la cuillère ça marche très bien
mais cela se sache
voyez vous voyez là on voit les fesses
et il a les bras
c'est incroyable et bien mon grand père
me faisait ça et tous les gosses à la
cantine vont faire ça à partir de mai
alors
tout à l'heure en examiner avant
passé par le passé au talk show que vous
arrive par exemple de changer de look
est ce que par exemple
moi j'ai un truc pour vous laisse que
vous mettriez est-ce qu'on peut venir
avec la veste pour arlette laguiller
non mais c'est pas quelque chose de
choquant simplement c'est une tenue dans
laquelle on vous a rarement vu c'est une
veste chanel c'est le modèle si c'est
moche c'est gentil
allez c'est pas moche c'est cher de mots
français françoise de panafieu le jeune
homme voulant lever tout de suite vous
la mettez c'est pourquoi j'ai bossé
françoise elle même et un survêtement
non c'est non pas
après bah moi je mets en fait bientôt de
la lys auto news est habillé raison vous
êtes en train de baisser
vous êtes en train de mixer simone veil
quand ma main a beau mais chacun son
sale gueule et dire mais si on peut
apporter la base
la voilà mais c'est joli d'attenté vous
avez vous avez ressemble à zazie factor
hier rocco siffredi qui dit moi je veux
pas prendre les vestes mais les filles
qui les amène c'est mieux de rêver non
match est inverse par exemple ça
marchera pas non plus ne voulait pas du
blues en ont plus la peine non regardez
regardez voilà ardisson redonner avec
jean gillet 100 m je met peu à peu et on
en parle plus je vais mettre la balle
allait donner sa tante ambulant en
question
mamie je m'habille aller
je mets la baisse
le père plus garder sa droite fabien
outre un hommage c'est très très bien
bon moi je suis habillé en julien lepers
pouvant rockeur là les enfants
ouais très datation je ne crois pas vous
refuser une belle chanel c'est votre
droit bien leur accès direct aux c'est
vraiment et il reste julien lepers pas
quoi josy mc s'avoue materi bon alors ce
qu'on va faire maintenant parce que
c'est parti pour julien lepers alors
vraiment pas bien julien ingénieur et
n'importe quoi bon vous savez qui est
une tradition dans cette émission savut
bien week-end où la bulle est en train
de marquer marquer des points
descendu à sa façon mais elle n'est pas
tête de liste aux européennes avec quoi
on parlait alors justement
l'espoir du fond il devance toulouse
comme quoi l'habit fait le moine parce
que ça va se terminer françoise de
panafieu va nous faire joey starr et
arlette sérieux dans cette émission une
tradition c'est qu'on chante
l'internationale robert hue la chanter
je les chante avec lui daniel cohn
bendit l'a chantée est ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour chanter le couple et de
l'international que vous préférez
d'ailleurs je donne à mes choix je
connais pas mais tu la connais non je
veux aller à 2,3 c'est la lutte finale
groupe on nous dit de marée de marco
c'est quoi ta tête et voilà ça c'est un
peu mieux pour moi
bienvenue à mort philippe candeloro
bonsoir ça on se connaît pas on ne sait
jamais vu connaissez mon ami on se
connaît oui et alors ça s'est bien passé
la première fois très bien très bien on
va vous faire une hyper view alors une
hyper view vous allez voir la lumière va
baisser dès que j'ai posé la première
question et recours peut vous poser des
questions
laurent pour vous poser des questions et
catherine peux vous poser des questions
et moi je vais pas me débarquer tout de
suite avait tout rocco siffredi qui
était un homme politique italien tu as
l'air en fait ça arrange comment alors
vous connaissez rocco siffredi non il a
joué dans d'argent il a joué dans doctor
who encore une histoire solo mélange
passait pas connaître le grand pardon
non par ailleurs
oui donc quoi aussi miss talent clitoris
meester
passer d'un jeune carrière
un peu comme vous ils brisent la glace
qui me dit quelque chose
même quand vous me parlez de blanche
neige et les sept nains bon philippe
candeloro donc après votre médaille de
bronze à nagano vous avez décidé de
passer pro c'est ça c'est fait
on retient pam a tort mais dites-moi
médaille de bronze à magog vous avez à
l'international vous n'avez jamais été
premiers n'ont jamais en fait jamais de
titre suprême donc ses skis en mer d'un
peu de monde les femmes ouais en fait je
suis autant voire plus médiatique que
certains champions du monde champions
olympiques donc ça paraît bizarre mais
bon c'est comme ça j'ai su enfin moi je
suis pour rien quoi on fait une tournée
qui s'appelle le camp del euros à tour
un quai de toi et donc professionnels et
surya bonaly c'est ça surya et ai été
avec moi donc on l'a on a fait une
première partie de la tournée sur civile
au mois de mars
donc comme c'est ma première tournée
j'organisais c'est moi le producteur
c'est moi qui fais tout bon c'est un peu
c'est un peu lourd
enfin je veux dire il ya beaucoup de
choses où il faut faire attention donc
c'est vrai que financièrement j'ai pris
encore un petit peu mal mais bon chaque
production en fait en diminuer le
déficit parce que vous aviez beaucoup de
problèmes d'argent avec la fédé à
l'époque voulait jamais vous donner ce
qui vous devez bien servi là pour cette
production
mais vous doivent toujours de l'argent
la fédération de vesa toujours pas été
réglée à la ferme c'est dingue je
voulais qu'on lance à la place dans les
avocats sans temps de s'en occuper 10
ans et s'appelle d'accord tout rendu
populaire candelo c'est d'abord sa voix
et sa tchatche parce que d'abord il pas
on lui pose la question il répond
maintenant et surtout il a cette
gouaille de titi parisien qui fait que
tout de suite les imitateurs se sont
emparés de lui
et alors même quand il parlait pas on
entendait on entendait la radio guignols
et ça c'est ça qui fait parler mieux en
plus un pardon pas les mieux pas les
meilleurs imitateurs des mois qu'il y en
a certains qu'est-ce qui est comment il
allait
un accès plus combiné sera il s'appelle
l' île en face de moi aujourd'hui mais
je me rappel puissant mais moi je suis
pas un buteur vraiment faire des trucs
pas mal ma gueule c'est vrai que c'est
je te remercie beaucoup les guignols qui
m'ont fait aussi un bon coup de c'est
comme ça vous avez un pc ou les mois je
me suis jamais y en a en fait je me suis
jamais fâché en fête avec eux et c'est
ça qu'il faut au minimum
voilà un mec qu'elle qui reste est sympa
parce que on pouvait dire les pires
conneries sur lui ça me faisait marrer
c'est pas comme si ça m'arrivait de
rigoler des propre connerie où il se
foutait de ma gueule
bah quoi j'allume ma télé pour regarder
les guignols ou une émission de
divertissement c'est pour rire c'est
pour lui avoir dit tiens il a raté un
triple saut ses parents eux l'ont réussi
par exemple ça c'était pas ça patine
justement qu'est ce que j'ai pu dire les
américains on nous envoie le cochon qui
parlent les anglais ont la vache folle
nous on a line qui patine
c'était pas un pas non plus et bas et
n'a jamais foutu son poing dans la
gueule c'est pas pour ce soir
à la sortie c'est soit là ou pas avec
les points je vais régler ça je vais
inviter sur la glace et puis tu
commences à passer voilà je vais souvent
une fois mon dieu je quittais pas la
rambarde
c'était terrible voilà le finalement
c'était pas moi alors en france c'est
quand même une réputation un petit peu
je sais pas si je me trompe vous
connaissez bien philippe mais un peu
grande gueule médiatiques quoi vous
c'est vrai vous parlez de vous la
troisième personne mais ça vous arrive
ça
non pas je parle
là comme je vous parle aujourd'hui on
vous dit jamais quand des comme alain
delon
j'ai dit une fois des lauréats soif
il ya trois semaines j'ai fait une
conférence de presse donc pour la
tournée du camp dès le retour il est
vrai que j'ai un peu employé
la troisième personne est en fait bon
c'était un peu une erreur quoi bon
boulot parce que de langeac pas je
regrette pas mais bon c'est vrai qu'il
vaut mieux parler de soi vomir jeu et
puis voilà hamas n'en parle plus moi ce
qui me fait rire
en tout cas chez candeloro et c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il a revolution nous
évidemment c'était du pain béni pour les
humoristes mais ce qui a révolutionné le
patinage c'est quand même qu'il venait
déguisé il a eu la main on allait venir
j'imagine c'est les costumes à chaque
mois je veux dire j'ai noté je me
souviens d'artagnan d'artagnan qui lucky
luke conan conan le barbare le para le
parrain skies euros non non non pas ça
en fait irina police mais le choix entre
d'artagnan et d'artagnan euros fanfan la
tulipe en fait s'ils avaient un choix
mais c'était cape et d'épée qui
m'interdisait de vue quelle panne au pli
pour noël dernier
là j'ai eu batman george de la jungle
george de la jungle c'est ce que j'ai
fait sur ma tournée
c'est ce mardi alors je faisais une
impro tous les soirs en fait peut
apporter le spectacle philippe candeloro
on dit souvent que vous faites du cinéma
du ce cinéma-là en tous les cas pour
cacher vos faiblesses techniques c'est
vrai pas la faiblesse technique plus la
faiblesse artistique parce qu'en fait
quand j'étais jeune j'aimais pas du tout
l'artistique et pour faire un mec qui
fait du patinage artistique c'est un peu
gênant quand même oui
donc c'est pour moi lever un bras ça
faisait ça faisait gonzesses et pis je
me lève aux copains hockeyeurs qui vous
disaient à colombes à vous et de
natation d'abord vos copains accueillir
vous disais que ça sport de [ __ ]
disait viens plutôt faire du hockey tu
verras puis finalement après on apprend
que les hockeyeurs finalement dans le
vestiaire il se mange pas
non je tiens
cette émission est passé sur france 2
juste avant celle qui est qui singe et
un cake est qu à la première fois que
j'ai rencontré rocco siffredi je lui dis
en faisait une interview un peu comme sa
carte d'identité disons et jeudi tata il
me répond tout de suite 25 centimètres
n'a pas du tout pensé à autre chose
alors vous
à l'heure qu'il est on peut en parler
jusqu'à sept heures et demie du soir en
plus je réponds toujours bad la taille
moyenne des français 18 cm on vous dit
ça en gros 18 ans a fait 19 ans il ya
mieux
moi je vis avait pendant la fille
parfois s'allonge un peu plus fort
pourquoi lors de l'émission qui est qui
quand la fille vous dit la question que
ça n'a rien changé à marie ange nardi
pourquoi quand elle vous dit pourquoi
vous répondez ça c'est insensé
quand même je sais pas parce que man et
les questions moins imposées que c'est
vraiment vrai alors c'est une question
qu'on vous a jamais posé jeune et jolie
fait penser à ça aussi non non je n'en
dirai jolis noms n'ont pas spécialement
mais je dis j'aime bien marié ange nardi
elle est mignonne mais je dire c'est pas
ça qui m'a fait penser à l'avenir je
mardi rire à mercredi mais oui mais non
je ne sais pas c'est parce que c'est
vrai qu'on en a jamais c'est la question
c'est qu'on n'a jamais osé vous posez
vous savez pourquoi parce qu'on n'a
jamais fait des missions ensemble c'est
tout il ya longtemps qu'il vous aurait
demandé alors dans les vestiaires de la
patinoire ocde qu'ailleurs il ya trop de
choses à raconter il ya même un film à
faire donc on va me un film à faire
la carte de monsieur alors quartier en
plus il ressemble terriblement depuis
qu'il est entré van damme oui pour moi
pour mon point de vue comme ça même
quand même non peut être avant dams et
doit faire un film tout de suite
produits et du x adacore du vix tout de
suite vous êtes prêt même marié les 18
centres parce que s'allonger un peu plus
à moi moi moi moi moi on m'a toujours
dit à moi m'a toujours dit beau tu es
bien sûr terminera parce que tu es une
grosse que oui mais c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment ça il ya eu des
grands acteurs du luxe comme les et
qu'ils avaient au contraire même 15 au
14 et ça dépend surtout comme tu le fais
bon on m'a parfois moi je défie qui
m'ont dit assez trop grand ça va me
faire mal je vais pouvoir s'acquiert a
refusé vous savez ça lors sinclair a
refusé jeudi par taylor sinclair a
refusé 2 j'ai bientôt jeune justin
bieber comme ça non mais heureusement
heureusement la pluie
la plus grand partie de foi compte à la
fin a décidé de la faire ouais ouais ils
m'ont jamais dire les bleus ça c'était
avant que ce que vous dites c'est que
les films pornos sont à la portée de
toutes les bourses
toutes les bourses les bons ça dépend
comme tu le fais mais sûrement la chose
plus important ça la passion que tu mets
dedans voilà attendait la nation ce que
vous dites là c'est une très bonne
nouvelle parce que philippe candeloro
dit quand on lui dit vais gagner
beaucoup d'argent il dit attendez moi je
vais terminer entraîneur à dix mille
balles par mois donc je peux prendre de
l'argent maintenant vous n'êtes pas me
le reprocher vous êtes peut-être une
autre façon de vous reconvertir après
bon pourquoi pas viser pourquoi il ne
désire rien de salace parce qu'il ya en
fait il est trop jeune maman profs des
films pornos c'était plus alban al gore
balle dans ses réer bien sûr directement
chez lui c'est vrai que les films pornos
bon roberto malone est plus tendance à
ça semble vrai qu'elle lui les plus âgés
mais on n'a qu'à regarder maintenant il
est fait je fais plus c'est quelque
chose là avec ma femme tu as regardé la
télévision quoi c'était à vous le faites
en vrai quoi ouais enfin je fais pas les
films mais ben ouais vous faites si ça
défile pas non non non pas encore posé
des questions à lardy sont maintenant ça
détend vous savez quoi non mais voilà
donc peut-être une nouvelle carrière
devant vous pourquoi pas mais à mon avis
avec ma femme ça risque d'être dur clair
pourquoi elle veut pas mais pourquoi
avec votre femme bon cinéma
après c'est ouais c'est un état d'esprit
après la récolte heureux de savoir
qu'après sept ans de mariage vous amuser
toujours beaucoup avec olivia c'est bien
c'est le bio c'est nul et bien
maintenant marié sur la dernière
question une petit gars la question mais
vous restez avec nous une petite
dernière question excuse dans le patin
il ya de la dope comme dans le vélo que
sa dernière émission on a vu à wad
menthéour qui nous ont raconté des biens
belles est ce que dans le patin il ya
deux le pcot des corticoïdes eu mal en
fait mon dans le patinage c'est quand
même un sport assez particulier se doper
vous ne pourrez servir à long terme sur
l'entraînement pour faire des charges de
travail beaucoup plus intense mais sur
le moment de la compétition là où il
faut être le plus fort c'est mentalement
c'est pas c'est pas physiquement ni
techniquement parce que le mental fait
tout un dernière c'est le mental c'est
comme rocco c'est pas comme le mental
savent pas la politesse des locales ce
nouveau plaisir
ouais le chat ne veut pas sortir non ça
veut dire de la cuve pas de pensée
politique dans le sens qu'il faut
vraiment penser à la belle fille qui tu
as en face rien de tout cela il faut
oublier tout le reste
ouais c'est le mental donc c'est une
tranche napolitaine
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir
non nous allons mais aussi des très
belles matin sa colère en vous a mis un
petit peu loin
donc c'est une émission c'est une
émission il vient tous acquis pour le
monstre de florence
donc cette émission a été transformé en
émission sportive généralement ici quand
des langues fait du patin rocco siffredi
qui fait des films x
marina inquiétudes et aux romans inédits
sur quoi vous gospel dire bon alors
marie sara on va vous faire une hyper
dur donc vous allez voir la lumière va
baisser mais voilà elle a baissé et moi
je vais arriver
oui mais moi ça me motive et un tube et
dès que la lumière est ce qu'on peut
baisser la lumière pour qu'un petit peu
d'intimité s'il vous plaît serge khalfon
voilà c'est mieux comme ça sent mieux et
vos yeux sont top dans cette lumière là
vous êtes même année ça qu il a
calmement
à l'avant les amis
il a déjà joué en double non
bravo longuet bon non on a voulu vous
invitez parce que si j'ai bien compris
m'arrive ça c'est votre dernière saison
oui ça c'est ma dernière saison s'arrête
quand à arles en septembre sera en
septembre lors d'une corrida n'a d'yeux
et là je commence donc ma dernière
saison
vous voulez pourquoi vous avez été
voulait arrêter au sommet quoi c'est ça
vous dit
il ya tout un tas de raisons bien sûr
personnel mais je voulais arrêter au sol
mais aujourd'hui j'ai fait une carrière
exceptionnelle je vais pas faire plus
j'ai inventé un métier qui n'existaient
pas pratiquement j'ai ouvert les portes
pour des femmes et puis voilà ça fait
donc dix ans que je t'aurais ça fait
même quinze ans que j'ai débuté et je
suis au top niveau et ça fait dix ans
que je me maintiens parmi les dix
premiers du peloton je peux plus faire
le plus aimé sortir en pleine gloire
vous avez votre fille ou s'il faut dire
j'ai une petite fille de 3 ans qui
s'appelle sarah luna c'est ça tout à
fait et donc j'ai pu vraiment le droit
de me jouer la vie trop souvent bien
donc je vous promets que cette émission
est réputé pour sa discrétion c'est tu
vas pas me demander combien de
centimètres
je voulais dire simplement qu'on sera
discret sur la vie privée de marie sara
parce que cette émission ces missions
discrètes on est des gens discrets je
regardais et aux taureaux sexuelles et
autres sections alors bon vous êtes
alors non il faut le dire comme la seule
femme torero août oreja au monde alors
il ya eu des femmes
il ya eu le coach est assez froide mais
à l'entente 30 dans les années 50 et
j'ai été la première femme qui a filmé
carrière vraiment internationale depuis
gucci yacine trône et il ya plein de
jeunes filles qui débute maintenant est
d'ailleurs la preuve en est à la feria
d'arles
cette année il ya de deux nouvelles
jeune fille qui débute et donc j'ai
vraiment inventé une profession dans lé
foot aurait à cheval parce que vous dit
effectivement que si une femme prend un
coup de corne dans le ventre
effectivement c'est pousser sais c'est
pas bien pour enfanter plus tard etc
c'est pour ça que la preuve si vous avez
eu un enfant oui n'y a pas que ça je
crois que la tauromachie à cheval est
plus approprié à la femme à pied c'est
très très violent il faut ça oblige la
femme avant une gestuelle très très
masculine
et il ya une ambiguïté qui se fait plus
le spectacle n'est pas le même
l'esthétisme non plus dire que les
toreros ils s'habillent un peu en
dentelle avec des perruques et où il
s'habille en femme les toreros c'est un
peu travesti en fin de compte chez vous
vous avez trois matches - et en plus il
ya un taureau qui lui la force masculine
normalement donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une
espèce d'ambiguïté qui
vous dites je vous dit que vous sentez
le entre vos jambes le coeur du cheval
battre quand le taureau approche c'est
tout à fait mouvement et c'est le plus
beau de la tournerie à cheval c'est
arrivé à mener ses chevaux par le
dressage et tout en douceur
de tels exploits et être complètement
maîtres de l'association dur ils sont
artistes ont leur demander des facteurs
this tic du charisme de la personnalité
dues aux finances et le cheval qui écrit
gros collier entendu toro et il a joué
il a dit vous devez jouer gros ouais
surtout un film en espagne tous les
droits
ouais j'ai eu une expérience bourdon le
sepa coeur du cheval entre les gens je
sentais plus de pâques
non juste un peu plus je sentais un peu
plus tôt montrent que ce serait non pas
ce que je faisais j'avertis marisa il
parle comme ça même comprendre
les sujets parce que j'ai fait un grand
rêveur
j'ai fait un grand rêveur ne vouloir pas
et d'essayer de pas vouloir le stand de
l'entrée rocky prends ma place pour le
grand boulot a pas du tout voulu et le
20 km en scène par le jeune à métaux qui
n'est plus là immédiat le côté sur ce
qu'on doit finir le film a beau temps
pour vous on doit finir le film donc je
rentre ce jeudi c'est toute façon c'est
un grand toro c'était 380 kg nos mamans
c'est pas de grand tour mais ça peut
faire mal et donc je dis je m'appelais
je mange bien toute façon je vais le tir
et un peu tu fais là plus de vieux je
m'étire
passage obligé des jumelles activé vers
moi je faisais bien ici et bougez pas
ils étaient ensemble et c'est bizarre
parce qu'il m'attendait donc bon il faut
que je sors en milieu de tout le monde
non je croyais qu'il venait cette [ __ ]
ya un doute mais on entre dans les
cantines est ressortie elle est partie
mais venus de compte comme j'ai fait la
première comme ça c'est bien mâcher map
attraper la jambe et mais comme je fais
review le troc ou gp2 le troc rouge
je me suis j'écoule tellement vite
d'erreur matin dans la maison on a paru
chez matra p il me courait derrière
comme un fou mais c'est elle c'est l
espérance de terribles sera du fait
justement on dit d'ailleurs c'est le
cheval qui porte les couilles mais vous
vous appelle quand même dounia corones
au venezuela
on peut pas ici on vous a fait place
dounia corones c'est vous dire
on me demandez pas toujours de traduire
les trucs un tradi non je parle pas des
lignes ans mais je peux te dire madame
qu'on y voir l'effet que toute question
tout et les femmes en espagne disent que
ce faire l'amour avec un torero c'est
quelque chose d'extraordinaire les
hommes y font là ils pensent la même
chose pour pour une tombe et là on pense
la même chose
vous pouvez aussi le saint le son du
taureau après volonté les couilles mais
ils font ça ils font ça existe ils nous
ont dit qu'ils font n'est ce pas croire
n'importe tué avalerait n'importe quoi
[Applaudissements]
et c'est sallie kerviel je vais être un
peu plus soft mais savoir si vous étiez
déjà pris un coup de corne
non non tu confonds pas surtout pour les
jambes je me pose moi déjà beaucoup de
chutes parce que je parle effectivement
le pire c'est la chute puisque
l'autoroute peut faire tomber de cheval
tout simplement
alors j'ai eu pas mal de fractures oui
mes coups de cornes vraiment non il
avait déjà joué à terville s'est vu
demander d'animal perdant qu'elle arrête
le chercheur et france 3 sur france 3 la
roque aussi beaucoup tu pourras les
territoires instables avec les vachettes
mais que la machette ue-mercosur vraie
vocation c'était un coup de foudre
j'ai vu une corrida j'avais 14 ans et là
je suis sauté les arènes et j'ai décidé
que celle est ma vie qu'elle n'était pas
dans le truc au départ vraiment voilà
alors en 91 effet votre alternative en
ckoi l'alternative c'est qu'on devient
docteur en tauromachie en quelque sorte
d'accord on est reconnue donc par les
professionnels par le public et et on
rentre vraiment dans la cour des grands
a bien commencé place intron là qui
habitait au mexique avait pu quitter
plus à parler d'union si le travail
était plus arrivé depuis 40 ans
c'était la première fois qu'elle se
remontrer en plus pour aller donner le
flambeau à une autre c'était incroyable
puisqu'elle était très habitué 2000 toro
conchita c'est une
c'est céder devant des saints 2000 3000
et 5000 un peu moins un peu moins de
1000 tonnes bon et là alors donc votre
carrière devient effectivement ce qu'on
sait hélas utilisé n'était pas pareil je
vous ai promis des disques est même
obligée de le dire c'est pas méchant
vous rencontrer henri leconte
mais j'ai réfléchi
ils viennent dire qu'elle aimait les
bêtes et donc vous rencontrer henri
leconte et alors là faut quand on vous
voit on comprend remarquer henri leconte
le lendemain du jour de la rencontre et
vous demande de vous épousez pouvez vous
demander votre main du taf et d'ailleurs
je l'épousé mais c'est fou vous avez dit
oui tout de suite vous êtes ici c'était
le coup de foudre asséné le coup de
foudre
j'adore les coups de foudre est dans
cette émission est à peu près un ou deux
coups de foudre il avait mal au dos et
là il faisait la culture
alors bon et là vous avez commencé aussi
à triompher non seulement dans les
arènes mais dans la presse people
hélas si ça fait rire jaune après la non
lucide
c'est pourquoi la presse papier des
journaux de prestige mais surtout autre
vidéo qui est vraiment d'ailleurs que je
peux juste salue ici poussé des gens
humbles et magazines préférés aussi le
père noël ça oui exactement si une sorte
de père noël vous connaissez votre vidéo
connaît pas mais c'était vachement
coller ou pu l'ignorer sida quand on
achète on peut le lire c'est après donc
là vous êtes donc devenu effectivement
une star des médias disent on vous êtes
les rites honnête non une fois on m'a
appelé reetone est quand j'étais au rez
dans le sud de la france d'ailleurs à
saint vincent de tyrosse et c'était
plutôt sympathique mais chut il serait
bien étonnant c'est mignon et là on vous
jeter comme des balles de tennis dans
les arènes ça c'est pas dit non mais
s'était vu ce jour là et alors vous êtes
acheter un mât avec henri leconte vrai
niveau initial sur la porte c'est vrai
c'est vrai comme a comme à dallas quoi
ces noms comme andalousie comme
dalhousie comme en espagne c'est de
tradition quand on a les vaches chevaux
de mettre le cheikh de l'élevage sur la
porte lorsque j'ai appris ça ce qui
tient les gens dit tiens c'est chez miss
et michel sardou
lorsque j'ai appris c'est que venait
toréer chez vous à la grande époque
christian clavier ça encore et serge
july de libération est relatif
c'est le patron de libération ne savait
pas où il était le patron de libération
il avait chez vous faire de la corrida
nuit à un bienfaiteur et quelques
petites vaches est heureusement
qu'arlette laguiller plus là parce que
les gens à lui passera savons la coupe
et or là on vous dit après on en arrive
à la fin de cette interview parce que
vous dites il y avait trop de paillettes
je me suis laissée un peu en yves réparé
par tout ça quoi pas mais c'est à dire
c'est pas vraiment ça c'est
qu'effectivement je suis de toute façon
décalage mois avec avec la vie entre
guillemets normal parce que je vis dans
un dans un monde décalé vu que je suis
dans un milieu complètement fermée sur
les routes avec un milieu d'hommes dans
des on se retrouve dans des villages
pourri en formant dalhousie pour touré
dans une corrida c'est minable parce que
ça fait partie ça fait partie du lot y'a
pas que les grandes arènes
c'est vrai que quand on est obligé de
vivre cette vie là et en plus on ait
besoin d'être concentré et ne pas sortir
de ce milieu là et de s'entraîner tous
les jours moi je fais six heures
d'équitation par jour même donc
donc c'est vraiment une vie ont
d'ailleurs c'est aussi pour ça qu'il est
en train de me dire là si vous avez une
vie concentré que le quand il faisait
pas six heures d'entraînement par jour
là non pas du tout mais on s'entraînait
pas au même public et puis c'est vrai
que ce décalage avec la vie à près de
tous les jours qui viennent c'est
compliqué et alors donc et vous êtes
souvenu au moment de votre vivant de ce
que vous disais votre grand-mère
magdeleine
je suis pas divorcer ouais mais bon
toute séparation les hommes sont
toujours de passagers le visage vous
était tout petit
ça c'est ma grand mère qu'elle disait
oui mais moi je le mange moi je le dis
pas je m'en suis souvenu mais je le dis
pas parce que je voudrais lagarde
oh mon dieu bon mari merci voyez on a
été extrêmement discret un jeu et à
poser toutes les questions qu'ils
voulaient vous êtes vraiment beaucoup
[Musique]